Mozambicans have waited more than 40
years for this moment
since the country gained independence in
1975 the government has fought a
guerrilla group turned political party
known as R enamel now a peace accord
means Mozambique we are here in good on
Gaza to tell all Muslim beacons and the
world that we've just given another step
showing that the march towards effective
piece is really reversible that be a
certainty in this piece the hope and the
future of Mozambique is promising
it says the Mozambicans who choose to
bury once and for all armed
confrontation the deal that will see
thousands of Rena Mo's members disarmed
was signed in going go sir National Park
that's been the group's remote military
base for more than 40 years what is very
symbolic Gorongosa is a strategic place
grown whose income goes everything
started and everything should stop that
is a symbolic vote for every Mozambique
[Music]
this is not the first time Mozambican
leaders have come together Ranallo was
formed after the country gained
independence from Portugal in 1975 and
fought the government in a civil war
that killed an estimated 1 million
people talks in Italy in 1992 ended the
war there's a big expectation from our
people for peace therefore we expect
that this meeting will lead us to a
quick that peace deal redefined Renato
as a political party thousands returned
to Mozambique but the group always kept
an armed wing and fighting is flared in
recent years something the group has now
promised to end the 1st of August 2019
is marked in our history as an
unforgettable date the day of the
reunification of the Mozambican family
this is a historic date because after
many years of conflict we as brothers
are committed to make peace for the
greater good that commitment will be
tested in upcoming national elections
which will see the peacemakers and
political rivals pitted against one
another at the polls charlotte Bellis al
jazeera